okay Donald Trump again is saying that
coronavirus is dying out and it's just
going to go away Donald Trump was
interviewed yesterday about his upcoming
rally in Tulsa Oklahoma disastrous idea
dr. Anthony foul he says I wouldn't go
to any large events including this rally
just not a good idea not a smart idea as
a pandemic is still continuing to rage
Donald Trump said now the rally's fine
because coronavirus is dying out
coronavirus cases are rising in 22
states including Oklahoma where you plan
to hold a big rally this week aren't you
worried about people getting sick no
because if you look the numbers are very
miniscule compared to what it was it's
dying out by the way we're doing very
well in vaccines and therapeutics also I
think there's going to be some big
announcements on that in the
not-too-distant future but no we're not
concerned actually Oklahoma has had a
very low rate relatively speaking it is
a little spike a small spike for a
specific reason but no we had over a
million people apply they have people
now days ahead lined up they have big
lines of people so Trump said the
numbers are minuscule the numbers are
not minuscule we were at one point
seeing 30,000 new cases a day we are now
seeing 23,000 new cases a day that's not
minuscule as I've already told you a
bunch of times this week many states are
seeing record spikes Texas Florida
Arizona etc we have more than 20,000 new
cases every single day people being
diagnosed with corona virus but there is
something that is truly chilling about
Donald Trump saying it will eventually
go away eventually it will go away and
his followers are so ignorant and so
desperate for Donald Trump to be right
that Trump in a sense is correct it will
eventually go away and his followers are
just ignorant enough that they might
give him the credit for it or at least
say look Trump was right all along now
let me explain what I mean by that
eventually even without a vaccine
eventually if the virus keeps spreading
and spreading and spreading you're going
to get to 70 percent of the country
getting the virus
and that is the threshold that is
believed to be the threshold for herd
immunity for something that is
contagious to the degree that
coronavirus is contagious now this is
important to understand herd immunity is
not a fixed number for a more contagious
disease you need a higher percentage of
immunity to get to herd immunity so
measles is so contagious that the
estimates are you need 95 percent
immunity to have herd immunity
coronavirus is less contagious as far as
we know than measles dramatically so and
so it is estimated that you need about
70% immunity now that could be a
combination of vaccinations and people
who've got and recovered from the
disease we don't have a vaccination
right now so in order to get to 70% we
would have of 330 million Americans 230
million would be infected with a roughly
0.7 percent infection fatality rate that
means about 1.6 million people would die
so Trump is right eventually it will die
out because so many people will have
gotten it that somewhere around a
million and a half will have died and we
will have herd immunity
that doesn't mean Trump is handling this
correctly that doesn't mean it makes
sense to have a crowd of 10,000 people
in Tulsa Oklahoma on Saturday and it
certainly doesn't mean that Donald Trump
deserves to be reelected so my view
continues to be if Trump gets another 12
to 18 months
this could wind itself down on its own
leaving untold death in its wake and you
will have trumpets who will be
reinvigorated and say Trump said it
would go away and it went away I guess
he was sort of right we can't take any
chances on that Donald Trump needs to be
removed in November we have four and a
half months until the election and then
it's two and a half more until he would
be replaced with Joe Biden meaning in 7
months total right we're talking about
January 20 21st 20th we could have Trump
gone coronavirus will Allah in all
likelihood still be a problem at that
point in time but we could at least
start to start to go back
to something that would actually
resemble sanity at that point in time in
terms of the decisions you have to make
over the next two weeks I would go
without she over Trump if you would go
with Trump over foul Qi I want to know
why if Trump says it's safe to go to a
rally with 10,000 people and foul she
says it's not I'm going with pouchy I
also live in Massachusetts where there
are no rallies of this size taking place
there are no events of this size taking
place and that's a very very good thing
we have a fantastic program coming up
for you today I will remind you that you
don't have to just watch clips on
YouTube or Facebook if you don't want
you prefer a daily one hour audio
podcast
it's available for free on iTunes
stitcher google play Pandora Spotify etc
I think I'm forgetting some and I
encourage you to subscribe to the
podcast you can also let me know your
thoughts about what is safe and what is
not safe as of right now on Twitter I am
on Twitter at D Pakman you can find me
there just don't troll me please don't
troll me